seule cette semaine je vais être huit
défaites deux victoires et je suis
descendu à 25
jallet 27 mai c'est quoi ton objectif
sur tu as calmes en termes de l'époque a
en fait c'est très con de jouer fatigué
quand elle à petit sur toi mais parle
peut-être qu'un jour je vais me motiver
je me fais trois jours à fond pour
passer 28-28 eu peu facile honnêtement
est facile de lâcher des 125 je suis
dans le top ten pour moi tu peux faire
entre eux 28 51 900 places à temps la
cadence en 3 0 par ici je suis vraiment
mettez [ __ ] tu es plus fort que moi
well aux échecs oui mais pas la souris
mérite même pas où 22,8 à la souris je
suis pas prêt je suis bien pour je peux
tu peux te montrer une par exemple que
j'arrive à quai hier et tu vas me dire
si c'était bien joué mais je la retrouve
notamment sur wii s'est arrêté de
regarder de faire des petites magouilles
dont je sais que le coach ne comptait en
montée j'avais bossé
enfin j'avais fait des erreurs pendant
deux semaines avant un tournoi majeur la
ritournelle comme ça
regardant quelques coups ils montrent
les poignées c'est ça je suis rentré
volontairement dans cette position
j'étais sûr que j'allais l'arnaqué très
vite en fait voyez du forcing 9,4
chauveau ouais c'est un premier piège du
pouilly fêter cinq voit pas et qui vient
en d4 déjà sur dame s'est cassé qui
avait lieu si ces prix j'avais fini cela
prend ok mais qui puis après il va se
prendre la deuxième qui va arriver il
faut ok c'est ça ouais donc j'ai moins
dès l'aube ou deux quand je sais mais
bon ça c'est typique genre de partie que
genre mac bien tu as genre de position
je sais que jarnac et j'ai perdu une
partie en trois coups avec les blancs
tafer comment ne suis rien
j'ai très très très mauvais réflexe ans
que j'essaye de jouer vite
non non c'est pas comme ça je te dis des
coûts globaux
je peux me rappeler si tu veux trois
points communs avec les blancs à temps
keller 3 ok j'ai près de nouvelles baies
3 on l'a méritée et c6 way d35
j'ai fait le cadre d'un lbo f 101 cas
lendemain c'est un gang déroctage mp3
très con égard très con vraiment très
con j'ai joué avec des trois jeux vous
souffriez six fonds bkc je me suis
vraiment pris 10 coups peut-être aussi
que tu as moins l'habitude d'avoir des
poubelles que moi mais des 3,5 4,5 je
pense qu'ils font ce cadre ses fautes
décisif
kiev 3 kgs 6 baies 3,5 pouces des trois
seuls pays où étroit pour jeux de cartes
et des quatre mécénat liquide moche mais
tu peux pas faire ça ouais mais tu dire
non oui mais en fait c'est moi qui aime
bien la théorie ça me déprime d'être
foutu un ou deux coups ouais mais
détroit savane on s'est donné trois fous
g2 et ouais ouais normal c'est fou que
ce soit avantageusement cet échiquier
horrible honnêtement il est attiré cet
échiquier wes avec fabre on s'est fait
un délire je vous emmerde autres
voulaient le cal attendons malchance de
chewing gum ses causes c'est horrible
mais dans les pièces à la limite mais
aussi l'échiquier que j'aime pas du tout
vivre et à l'échiquier a tu veux quoi
transparent ça doit être dégueulasse
aussi non horrible oh oui
est ce que ça te pète le pire que les
chicanes de clocher non elle tous faire
et que fabien est vraiment d horribles
un gorille non mais je vais remettre le
l'habituel quoi celui là il est bien
alors attends je vais donner le lien du
tournoi au joan jett
ouais en fait on a fait une vieille
partie pour les vieilles parties on va
prendre c'était chic est pas un
l'intrigué passé ouais là moi je me
régale en ce moment il ya le championnat
du monde des ordinateurs
ouais je sais fabien m'a dit je regarde
sans arrêt voilà tous les chevaux et on
dirait c'est tout j'ai le truc ouvert il
ya des idées de fou parce qu'en fait
c'est désormais qu'on ait une répartir
second très fin du coup ils
réfléchissent très tôt il ya des idées
de malades c'est quand je regarde les
championnats du monde failli à trop 80
par correspondance et des cas une partie
la mettre en ligne
j'adore les mecs c'est des fous furieux
myv forcément
non mais bon j'ai vu un truc genre de
4,5 montrer à quel point les mecs sont
barrées donc berlinoise et a troqué ses
6,9 et 5,6 rock qui est pas un cat sauve
un cahier des six est là donc tout le
monde est ok prince ouais mais qui les a
joués fouet f1 donc sans doute sur
fossati transpose l'injuste là le mec
est mort à fébé si m6 garde le pion et
blanc b4 c'est parti dans le grand
n'importe quoi mais genre ça va vraiment
un bon coup
farage c'est c'est correct mais c'est le
meilleur coup probablement apprécié et
je m'en aille plus de la partie c'était
un truc genre
à 6 et le mec a balancé un des quatre
cavaliers f7 et un petit coup d'a3 et
après il a joué fo b2c 4 kgs c3i l'ajac
l'otan - mais les compenser il a fait
nul mérité mieux mais c'est assez drôle
c'est du jamais vu
a berné mais il doit avoir des doigts va
voir des machines de malades quand même
pour faire tourner je pense que là c'est
pas une question de machines parce que
le marché va consacrer mes parents c'est
il faut être obstiné et après analyse
est comme un malade parce qu'en fait si
tu mets b4 l'ordi 20 mhz et égale donc
ça veut dire qu'il ya des compensations
pour l'option oui non mais c'est juste
penser à ça normal peut-être que le mec
il a fait feu par erreur sur leur disque
il inverser les coups et elle a vu que
c'était pas qu'on est du coup là je
meurs mais ok tu t' il aurait pu
transposer avec force est juste ouais
ouais
ou alors il a trouvé autre chose mais
sachez pas au courant mais ouais des cas
quel point 530 mais t'as rien on sait de
la rampe de toute façon bien assez comme
manny savez je cherche pas du monde qu
alice est roi et où des quatre il ya des
mignonnes peu à la mode c'est un peu
joué le jeu pour un petit plus urgent le
cecos il ya un match car ça ne sert à
rien on fait un match de bullet cette
nuit sur l'it chasser fil rouge a gagné
103 90 103 1 c'est un gros match mais je
crois vraiment qu'ils les formes c mais
est ce que ça peut être le genre de mec
qui peut faire vous progressez incarne
aussi motivés ou pas il faut aussi faire
arrêter les échecs il peut l'envoyer à
l'ehpad 1 ouais non mais vraiment
vraiment un facile le bas il peut le
décourager bonjour mes liens du tournoi
je te montre notre découverte de cette
semaine une partie d'ordi vas-y premier
coup le caire 3 qui est 6
disons c'est quoi lors de coups c4 c5 et
ses trois caisses et 6 des 4 puis en
prend car je prends aussi donc langlès
de maxime médard en jalles 3 pouces et 5
déjà c'est un peu rare qui a et b 3e
sets où j'ai deux rock rock des cinq
nouveautés grimpions comprend qu'elle
valait franquet prend 2 me prend d'un
prend vous prend vos avis et n'auront
fait nul facile tour est vite qu'ils
avaient quatre fois f5 il faut aussi ses
études développement
ouais c'est mieux pour les blancs mais
c'est fou quand même ça c'est jouable
puisque des cinq seuls à vraiment coup
en fait c'est très bon fait frire à long
terme tu files le pion et après j'ai
vérifié il n'y a pas d'égalité que les
repères mais c'est pas con c'est
beaucoup moins qu'on finit par y par
exemple il ya des idées dr b1 qui pourra
logique pour sortir le coup c'est de
prends ça marche c'est un truc à une
fois je crois kébé 4 tu te donnes un
autre pion mais il hyper-actif l'hyper
content dans la nef wells 5 calfo g4 il
tord sewage sais plus dans quel ordre
des fois il fait ça tournait vite
yverdon et égalise très vite il prend
ses aises prend b2 c'est fou non
aïe j'ai complètement dingue non non je
fais moi je kiffe derrière des as mais
je comprends tout le monde aime pas un
c'est fou ça me fait penser un peu tard
oui mais bon
non mais si des cinq marques c'est juste
ça rêve c'est à dire que l'anglais est
un troll mais honnêtement j'ai vérifié
c'est qu'elle inclut probablement
partout mais sans doute que con ça veut
dire que contre un andy tu gagneras
jamais ces finales wpt est ce qu'au
mieux tu as quatre contre trois
à la fin trois rois tour contre euro à
quatre contre trois essais nul ou avec
influençable
d'une aussi ça dépend du roi avec les
fous sur la même aile de même couleur
c'est nul ouais bah il vaut mieux se
soit pas sûr que leur opposer d'ailleurs
comme il ya des toits oui mais a
toujours son destin fixait me fous des
cinq pions le cad pour cela 7e mais ça
je les avais regardées en fait ce que si
tu échanges les tours c'est nul c'est
échange les fous c'est nul et le fou il
apporte rien puisqu'il est de la même
couleur que l'autre fois mais il faut
que ce soft même couleur il faut que ça
fout d'eux mêmes couleurs ouais enfin
c'est marrant mais c'est pas très
marrant au final ça veut dire qu'il ya
un an il va y avoir encore plus de
femmes au fur et à mesure ça est de pire
en pire quoi ouais mais en fait le truc
c'est qu'on se plaignait qu'il y avait
plus d'idées toutes les lignes était
chiant ce maintenant est là depuis deux
ans est différent il ya plein de revenus
au oui mais une fois qu'on aura épuisé
ce répertoire là on va on va encore plus
s'enfoncer je pense mais je suis pas sûr
parce que regarde je pense que ce type
xo sacrifice de pyong les blancs ils ont
dit coûts qui leur donne un petit
avantage d'une main a de bonnes chances
de perdre rapidement typique des
nouveautés tout être que fameux truc
j'ai analysé après les communales
oui oui reste hippique de genre de
nouveauté ou en fait mis dans les mains
m'a alors dit cette réforme est en
réalité c'est pas terrible
bounce non mais c'est pour ça que c'est
intéressant je pense il y en a plein qui
vont se faire avoir dont moi peut-être
ce jour par jeu et un truc qui a l'air
bien alors dit mais qui en fait elle
durera veux mes joueurs ça ça m'a fait
halluciner cédé 5 c'est le couple
torride jouer mais juste y croient pas
quand et humains séjour alors combien de
personnes pour l'instant c'est pas assez
33 pour le moment mais les jours tu sais
c'est bizarre pendant ce confinement
mathieu c'est que tu as des jours tu as
beaucoup plus de monde deux jours tu en
as - et c'est pas vraiment accès
explique alain version qui les gens
travaillent plus un jour plus un monde
plus qu'un autre je sais pas comment ça
se passe optez ce qui se dit je
travaille un jour sur deux ouais je sais
pas exactement et aya cristal qui est
qui et la voilà ça fait plaisir de voir
crypte talent j'espère qu'il sera là
dimanche soir en vous contre le pérou à
21h30
je sais pas si tu sera des nôtres
mathieu les va falloir les lilas il a
claqué au péruvien dimanche soir je
crois 21h30
c'est pas le pérou ya des montées qui va
peut-être jouer le championnat de
lituanie de glisse sur internet samedi
soir assez cool ça doit quand on disait
des modèles pour exprimer des trucs tu
as faux avec elle se met à stream elle
pourrait venir streamé dans la chaîne d
un tournoi je signe a pas de stream
obligatoire papa de kad oui mais
peut-être qu'elle a envie de stream et
parce qu'elle veut devenir streamer en
devenir frimeuse non mais franchement il
a pris du plaisir la dernière heure avec
toi elle a refait une fois en russe
c'était pas si mal après le système
était qu'on leur utiliser teamviewer à
distance pour joli coup avec du log
arena ben ouais mais bon c'était c'était
avec karina quoi bref elle émet des
marins connais rien là voilà c'est le
démarrage
un jour tu cherche quelqu'un de
différent en art devant nos gueules
non mais il ya pas mal de gens qui me
disent ce serait bien d'avoir un peu des
filles sur les streams en ce moment il
ya plein de gens qui m'écrivent ça ça
manque un peu de 22.2 ceni pour no
comment ouais ça joue sajou basse écrite
avec les blancs ne cryptent chez qui se
sont honnêtement je ne sais pas qui
c'est en vrai du tout mais le truc c'est
qui suit les live et que et que je le
vois ça a aidé la femme - en ce moment
se fait quelques mois voire presque un
an qu'on le voit beaucoup plus rarement
mais dans un moment il était là surtout
les lives grippale fenêtre os x c'est la
mode ce bundle l'idée bizarrement c'est
quand tu vas faire caler des 5
je vais te laisser faire keller 4 et tu
vas laisser ton fond de points parce que
le faut car il a seul pu être jeu et on
est prêt à rendre un pion intervient
comme on en peut plus d'accord tu peux
dire excuse moi j'achète pour mieux les
visaient le chat gt gt à ben je me suis
perdu mathieu nault su que c'était une
idée intéressante lashes d'ailleurs que
parmi leurs coûts parce que si tu joues
quel dessein que tu attaques et déjà
cavaillé il en reste le joker
l'idée c'est de laisser le jeu manque là
il ya soit 4 soit cavaliers bouge donc
si tu veux forcer le cavalier à bout je
fais pas çi hilali des taureaux un sens
très bien je veux tu veux laisser le
truc et et après tu te développe vite
c'est la boule c'est la dame bouge pas
prêt tu prends un jeu des quatre est en
fait tu vas jouer contre le cabba
structurants pions d'un point de plus
qu'un malade donc il est là une des
idées c'est faux f1 maintenant les
blancs sont fait avoir
le foie et a réussi à bien sûr la grille
noire teulière sont fait avoir
dénonçant faire reprendre les blancs
sont ok oui ils sont justes tant qu'il
ya du sang vrai live à un point de plus
et en plus ils sont pas moins bien
développée par ailleurs à 5 très mal
placé le foie est fantastique idée blanc
qui avait les attaques les avocats le
cavaliere elle est enceinte rôle féminin
cadet pas mal wayne is une perte de
temps et il fallait quand même prendre
en d3 mais du coup intéressant pour un
mot griffonné y ça lui permet de
d'apprendre d'apprendre quelque chose
très maître fide et même massive aulas
tu apprends encore ah bah oui on a aimé
le connaître des grands maîtres ont
perdu avec les mois savais pas ce qu'il
faut faire si un coup un peu un peu
bizarre mais c'est pas m mais c'est du
cristal très dangereux bah déjà il a un
boulot je crois qu'ils les 2100 quelque
chose en feed
s'il n'y avait pas eu de changement de
règle de la prod classique on l'aurait
peut-être pris un oui jusqu'à 2100 tu
vois mes bonbons sur le net tout ce que
moi je pense vraiment qu'il ya une
grosse différence avec ou sans en être
un peu d'honnêteté obligé flèches bien
joué mais internet
ouais tu arrives pas moi non plus la
motivation de change
en pratique je pense je suis pas
ridicule à chaque fois mais ce que c'est
plus loin je suis à fond mon jeu sans
internet j'ai du mal à me dire je vais
être à bout parfois tu donnes un
objectif que oui et c'est pour ça que
c'est ce que tu ta leur faire une série
se dire un jeu bizarre et je vois que ça
pour moitié mais tu veux tu veux essayer
de série mais
tu vas essayer de stream a road to demi
de la fsss en 2005 non parce que si tu
fais un road tu as faux que faut avoir
un gros avoir un vrai objectif tu vois
on ne sait ni l'a fait 3000 noms cabon
en scène un millier hockey et c'est un
mec qui m'usent depuis je pars me
d'année il est quand même pas moins à il
n'est pas mauvais mais j'ai reçus en
scène a fait 3000 sais tu veux faire
ouais après sur internet et les piscines
autre plus fort que moi tu pouvais pas
jouer au foot et trois rounds avant le 4
cavaliers pour je prends une fosse est
en fait tu pouvais sûrement mais bon
dieu c'est pas c'est pas casse a bien
travaillé à c'est quoi cet échiquier ça
me rappelle les vieux livres des chèques
en france est passé l'idée en fait c'est
la journée rétro aujourd'hui il est
moche tu trouves ait que changer des
pièces
allez on change les pièces je sais pas
ce que je ne préférais avec femmes on
aime bien celle là une pièce originale
ainsi tu aimes pas le moyen salle de
jeux ça c'est les préférés de ducasse du
staff et merci à bien peine label 100 is
parisse pour le switch prime et
recyclage j'aime bien ça là tu aimes
bien c'est les préférés de notre mike du
staff moi c'est le plus ouais ouais bof
est idiot de faire mine basse et les
pièces mer de glace moi il s'agit bien
ici si tu connais même si jamais je ne
veux pas tu joues à paris si si j'ai un
compte j'ai jamais joué
lalanne or l'époque où je jouais
beaucoup c'était sûr kasparov pièce
quatre mois j'ai beaucoup joué aussi au
real c'était le seul chiffre que j'ai
beaucoup j'avais un monet et après j'ai
arrêté de jouer après j'avais un compte
itunes
impala dire super fiesta pas
d'adversaires j'étais dans l'été dans
les biens classés 1 / kasparov pièce un
mot si j'étais vraiment pas je pense
qu'on a déjà dû on a dû jouer pas mal de
fois sur kasparov caisse c'est sûr
j'adorais ouais je sais que c'est
kasparov pièces notamment ce site là qui
m'a permis d' un peu me débloquer contre
les grands maîtres en partie rapide est
longue ce que j'envoie été beaucoup et
du coup le premier grand maître que j'ai
battu en partie réelle en rapide pas
remplis de ciment rapide
c'est un gars que j'ai débattu sur
kasparov pièce est en fait comme j'avais
un meilleur score que lui sur kasparov
chasse j'avais joué la partie genre on
avait rejoué une ligne qu'on avait joué
ensemble déjà sur le site ne savais pas
que c'était moi mais moi je savais que
c'était lui j'avais suivi genre les 20
premiers coups d'un truc que j'avais
analysé parce qu'il veut jouer tout le
temps et je l'avais gagné la finale
comme sur internet
tu as vu les noms peuvent déjà fin nul
breaké à 3 kg de boeuf ou prend ce qui
est non et kasparov chaise copine à
tordre mans c'était le site qui avait
créé kasparov
ça existe depuis 20 ans ouais à l'époque
il y avait eu des problèmes financiers
dont il avait sa juste valeur
mais ça ils sont plus que bons malades y
avait un reportage sur arte où je sais
plus quelle chaîne télé vous avez parlé
l'histoire de kasparov et je crois que
ça a complètement fait faillite face et
n importe quoi à 13,6 un coup et prendre
un mail à quai pour ces 4 il faut
prendre mais deux c'est bien maintenant
qu'elle pouvait penser qu est d'abord je
suis a préféré garder le détroit du wes
est bizarre sans fin il ya f4 emprise je
vous prendrai sans équipement haircut
peu bête ok tu veux faire peut-être tour
prend tour à 5 et 3 ça tu vas y c'est
deux heures ils avaient vingt secondes
c'est qu'ici il s'en était sorti deux
ouais ok maintenant faire h4 vite tu
caches tu caches ta tour et tu va rater
quoi
vachement sous jouer l'attaqué avec les
blancs gilet mieux autant il peut faire
après à deux secondes par coup un net
il est dangereux il m'a déjà battu mais
s'il ya un lien ouais mais il dangereux
moyart il en avait pris une foudre
je crois que c'était pas là ce n'était
pas une bonne idée ça de laisser sortir
le roi waimes bien il fait pris ces deux
dans ce but à la fin
je pense que c'est ce qui va faire pour
ces gitans français de sa force là mon
nom j'ai repris avec lautour d'ailleurs
pareil mais bon ok ça force à bondues
cas s'il peut pas doubler sur la
première il a tort ceux ci se font
prendre bien ou tomber oui et puis de
façon illicite sur un premier recul d'un
échec à matt aider en 4/3 on va
retrouver un paquito fimo qui avait
acquis a été dangereux qui joue ne s est
levé 4 5 c 4 c'est quand même con sekkat
c'est vraiment con c'est une scandinave
avec ça même épreuve
j'ai commencé à jouer ce gang il a
depuis deux trois jours sur internet des
4,5 en blitz est pas si mal après
jusqu'à un certain niveau
par contre hier je veux comptera 28 40
grands maîtres sur jazz comme donc je
passe d'atteindre en est à 25 entre 25
et 26 quoi et je me suis fait défoncer
avec les noirs et les blancs sont un peu
nuageux 3 qui est hkd
c'est frustrant mais c'est quoi l'idée
de des 4 5 il a une vraie alors des 4 5
pions procès si sky 3d si ce qui ne
m'intéresse pas d'accord je vous fais le
pion je te prends en gros je me fous
j'ai quatre à vingt sept gros rock à
l'ancienne
ça me rappelle les vieilles scandinave
je jouais qu'alexis quand j'étais petit
est des idées comme ça dis donc c'est
pas c'est pas jojo mais en blitz si
jamais été contre des mecs qui te domine
dans l'ouverture qui ont un meilleur
répertoire que toi ô toi c'est pas si
con en bis
moi quand je vois ce que je voulais en
anglais de ses lumières du monde je ne
dis bien que la science n'est pas le
plus important
non mais je veux dire par là que si tu
cites est dans le dur dont l'ouverture
il vaut mieux jouer ça que de ce fait
réciter 15 coups et que le mec est un +0
60 où il connaît tous les plans il vaut
mieux directement
tu vois ce que je veux dire après ce que
les mecs je brûle moins leur répertoire
du soleil dit m ils jouent pas leur
répertoire à fond si tu veux mais le
truc c'est quand t'as pas du tout le
répertoire comme moi par exemple même si
vous leur répertoire 2 ça leur suffit
pour être mieux c'est ce que je veux
dire qui a veillé à 4 s'était pas bête
mais bon tu pouvais faire un dessin
aussi pour t'ouvrir la colonne c'est
mieux mais toi tu veux pas du tout un
répertoire j'imagine a réussi sur
internet
ouais enfin ça dépend mais ouais je sais
pas en fait j'aimerais bien mais juste
maintenant on peut pas comme se
télécharge
oui mais donc c'est ça aussi qui te qui
fait que tu joues mieux en partie real
alors ça fait une énorme différence dans
ce match surtout que c'est mon point
fort bah oui c'est assez énervant
cette fête est perdre 100 points elo nom
ne pas avoir ton répertoire en lice je
pense en noir est donc ouais c'est un
peu je suis pas rapide donc ça m'aide
pas je gagne pain français 6-2 6-3 mais
c'est peut-être risqué de le pointer
food timorés je vous prends 1 3 c1 coupe
dans cette fois il faut des casses les
pièces d'un transat a que deux à trois
cents d'écart aux incroyables
c'est quand même parce que ça gagner il
faut des quatre nuits
je n'ai joué l'année dernière j'ai
déchiré un métier 28 50
moi j'ai joué l'an dernier en pro choice
league
j'étais mieux et il m'a armes à quai et
on a fait l'annoncé aujourd'hui oui mais
j'ai rien en fait j'avais complètement
dominés et j'avais pas être tu fais de
l'effet taux et demi sur 3 contre les
petits zambiens là qui sont tous passés
25 et cette année je serai content de
faire le même score mais un vote cdc des
hyper triki tron avec ce rythme de jeu
au compteur mais moi là juste pour dire
la partie contre le petit saint denis
l'ouverture j'ai halluciné quoi parce
qu'il était déjà fort et déjà 24 quand
je les jouais mars toujours un échiquier
du mali je peux te montrer
c'était des cadres des quatre car il est
si j'avais fait fou g5 dû coûter
s'allonge avait bouffé parce que je
m'étais dit je pensais que tu leur badge
et avait donc je suis un futur en fait
relève j'aime bien j'avais fait que 3i
la ffu les quatre échecs ces trois fous
des 6 et j'avais réussi à les laisser
profiter de trouver quel je crois que
j'ai voulu profiter parce que je me suis
que c'était comment et j'ai été mieux
mais a fallu six de toute façon ces
trois en aucun cas c'était un coup perdu
pas oui c'est bien mais moins - la
partie c'est realz c'était hyper bizarre
cette scène je veux 4 mai d'une pierre
qui décide et qu'est ce qui est si ce
qu'ils essaient 3g si je réfléchis dix
minutes ce que j'ai à l'affiché ce que
j'avais dans la base j'avais joué f4
contient quatre chefs j'ai veillé ni
j'avais jugé 5
du coup j'ai changé je ferais fkc fin de
ma prépa et les non en fait je me suis
dit c'est que des fois avec les blancs à
la mode c'était des quatre clips 6 x
tekken 6 ou f4 et là le site a dit
jessica et c3 et ça s'était très bien
passée il avait joué à 6h trop j'ai fait
h3 b5 le 5
alors ça c'était improvisation totale
mais je menace d'un maire 3 et cavaliers
à chaque c'était la partie à mon avis
faut aux trois ans et j'avais gagné très
facilement parce que là déjà il a des
petits problèmes je peux me lasser
fougueux ou g4 ou g2 et les toutes les
finales vont être mieux que j'ai la
caisse des cinq je suis mieux développés
est avait gagné ou pas bon après
maintenant ils ont vas tu qu on a perdu
notre parti vont avoir une on va en voir
une autre
vlada sera contre ricard où il manque un
pion alors comment s'est passée sa lutte
0 44 milles qui dit ça il a fallu qu à
l'efs les mecs que la famille si jamais
tu connaissais pas l'abréviation mathieu
asie puis à l'efs
non ce ne se bat que la famille si ici
toi même tu l'option de ces dommages et
il a disparu tentative de la répétition
de coûts avec 2 me de carélie e4
tactique ça marche ça marche
il peut prendre b2 va marchera peut-être
fausse mais moi je recycle être passé du
coup le piège des surprises crise prises
étudierait tour avait d'ailleurs on peut
prendre un an 80 ans il à faire [ __ ]
en b2c 4
je suis pas grand chose le cul élèves de
fawe poulina tort dit c'est que la
française faut pas que la famille que la
france est assez drôle tu vas pas l'air
d'être très sensible à l'humour de
l'élite
en fait je me rate grave de dire qu'est
ce que tu me dis que ça voulait dire que
la famille qu'est la famille t'écoutes
pas pnl je ne coûte rien - mathieu on va
te vas tu remettras pnl et ses copines
elle c'est un chanteur c'est un groupe
ses deux frères maintenant je sais pas
si on peut appeler ça des rappeurs mais
faut lui faire écouter au dd ouais ça on
l'a envoyé à cause de ma femme et ont
entendu et le remix sur deschamps nous
parce qu'il ya un gars qui à part au mix
fantastique sur des chambres d'aidé il
est très heureux de deschamps quoi
saluer tan tan il est souvent là je
développe mon moi les normes de clown
triste
ils sont en gestion s'est pas fait
encore voir la frêle à la main bitstream
aulas a perdu six tours seuls huit fois
fuite on consolide attention aux pièges
et 5 mtg cinq tours 3 mathieu et
valenciennes 1-1 l'ancien temps même les
pièces et salue cyril of au ddr et à
écouter du coup tu as aimé ou pas vous
n'était pas spécialement qua non mais
c'est rigolo enfin - à l'intérieur ce
nom c'est comme ça que j'appelle ma
femme tu l'appelles pas au décès n'ont
pu se décider maintenant ce terrible
ah ouais parce qu'elle a gardés dans
cette bd c'est dans ce décès est là elle
a gardé son ancien nom quand même l art
changer le nom de son fils au début avec
le mien et fred weill marc donc lé corps
net de l'i de l'it et l'insolite et
cordialité corps
ac non dans le sens c'était vraiment le
cd1 à me2 c'est qu'on comptait malteurop
à échanger discuter un rayon qui n'en
mettais plus pas pnl donc du coup fourré
un sillon way we non mais ça bien sûr
réinvestissons pam et écouter un peu de
rap quand même à l'époque non criminelle
n'était coûter un peu je 113 aussi ouais
ouais si si si si mathieu c'était
c'était la racaille des tournois pour
ses un an plus tôt bref c'était la
racaille des tournois par an dans morel
je peux tu joues bien en brenne quand
c'est vrai que quand on sait les
tournois je rappelle jonathan la même
chance que tu étais du brel et j'aime
bien toujours pas mais c'est bien moi
aussi j'aime bien brel montage mais
c'est vrai contre jacques brel et pnl ya
quand même un ya un gouffre quoi ouais
j'ai gens de bien jouer suite à brassens
est aussi ressorti peut-être non oui
brassant steve pas moi même et je
connais moins j'aime bien j'adorerais
johnny aille c'est pas mal alors attends
je n'ai pas rabat que le truc de vieux
te vois ça et on peut aller voir
alouette alouette pas qu'un local roche
tient en retrait
non c'est une position ferme et saint
yaguen couleur blanc tu peux attaquer
milliman en fait ouais les pruneaux il
est dangereux
af capte bien joué
pour prendre un bain de bouche je te
rappelle que ces gars je crois que c'est
quand le stream avec toi ou avec samy on
asic bruno il est riche qui trichent sur
sont éloquents bon alors qu'il faisait
la même particules avec accueilli siens
j'en perds mais pour je mange ans j'en
profite pour montrer aux gens que l'on
peut jouer une bonne partie en dameuse
chômage tm 2 c il s'ajoute trop vite en
fait je trouve
oui panique mais c'est encore chose que
tam 17 tu vas revenir mais c'est pour ça
tu pouvais mettre le rouge 3 et je donne
dès cet été même mieux encore par anton
fortement le fou sien et qui est le
fossé à troyes le quai à 5/4 la gueule
joker ok tu faire date 17 noms voilà qui
est français cas demain il va perdre la
finale à windham 17 faut aller chercher
le père pète tard et 7 à bercy ce nom
doit prendre ses trois adjoints prendre
g5 ça aurait peut-être juste échange hy4
j'aimerais pas ça le donnant la paire de
pilotes
j'adore sabrine tegra d'un grand fan de
sabrina un pas des clips surtout du clip
en ce qu'elle n'a pas fait son nid du
fameux qui sait pas ce qu'ils la gagnent
allées du rap laquelle jean marie feron
f2f seront en fait t'as juste pas
beaucoup le choix
mais si tu fais ça qui avait 6 mai et
cinq us qui dopent prince a bougé se
moque avaline mais oui c'est le bon plan
digues et or h1h1 tour à tour 5 pour
revenir comme ce que tu es tourache
entourage 5 imac et value c'est
impossible
ouais mais suroît g3 et ouais il aurait
fallu maintenant il fait maintenant il
faut tout racheter
oui mais on sait bien jeune et aurait
vraiment fallu pouvoir jouer des tours à
gissac ici we know qui devrait s'imposer
contre le leader attend sans frais
général n'était pas très bien vu non non
non il était bon train
au début tu es mieux que après la 21e
étape at il dit qu'elle est toujours
d'actualité sabrina voilà ma ville a dû
prendre un petit coup dur et je n'ai vu
y'a pas si longtemps un concert d en
russie cézanne ans le concert des stars
oubliées
fâché elles sont même pas oublié parce
qu'ils continuent à faire des concerts
tout le temps j'en ai tout au cutugno et
où ils viennent quoi sans arrêt pour 2/3
de trouver un voeu et sabrina non non
elle était encore vraiment pas malin
franchement lycée cadets peut-être rien
de cas et mes bas pèse aussi cordiale
est toujours au top kate tour g1 et une
harpe et j'espère que j'aurai fait gekas
et jouer la finale le pion s'est pas
fait en corse et savez prendre vu il ya
deux jours il pouvait le défendre avec
3,5 un monitorage des réfugiés 5.4 ces
trois fours ou un solide qu'est s'est
pas fait encore non encore voir le temps
et en moins de temps
tours est ce qu'il vaut on sait pas ici
mais c'est pas mal parce que sur wuala
il fait autour des 3 ça s'est un peu
trop solide bref trois menaces flash 4
iphone t3f un bon mais on réfère 5 la
pharaonne tu peux le faire tout le temps
ne va pas la tenir je pense s'il ya ça
qui tombe elle est dure il faut chercher
le patri les noms on peut pas rentrer en
cours ce science ici tu peux je mets des
guillemets mais faut partir pour que la
paix d'esprit mort je peux remettre un
lien si on est déjà cendres c'est mieux
ouais mais on est quand même beaucoup
dans ces tournois mais sans c'est bien
se passer
non c'est bien c'est bien mais je pense
qu'on peut monter à 150 commirent du
club sont donc là glénan faut chercher
le passé quatre échecs encore mais on
associe les rois ces six options prend
pour apprendre pour v8 et a fait qu'ils
tombent 2006 mais tu vois ça peut être
chez quiche écrit encore à bien sûr on
est là pour ça d'ailleurs
trois des quatre français mais 6 le plan
c peut bien main s'attaque là tôt quatre
échecs mais pour ces huit là je pensais
faire courser 7 machin c'est avec ce
séjour c'est nul
dans ses murs et cissé il envoie le
contre parce que roi des de p67 en
français de roanne le droit c'est ça
ouais surtout pas qu'ils reculent
cherchons faut avancer à tâtons elle
était déjà bien placé
à ce niveau là ils savent pas aller
chercher le contre eux avec leurs pions
c'est qu'on m'aime et je sais qu'il faut
juste tumulte an dernier le plan qui
pousse le tien qui monte on retrouve
sacrifier la tour et tu va forcer la
thora birch a qualifié contente d'un if
you don't have a fait un nul ça les gars
c'est hyper intéressant
pédagogiquement pour vous messieurs
voila voila tu prends et tu mets ton
rang c5 ou en bessin car si c'est une
honte
et d'ailleurs il ya un truc qu'il faut
toujours vérifier si les coups comme
tous rêvent 6 il y avait la tendance
aussi à winnipeg mais normal de donner
b6 et des six là il suffisait de droit
c'est simple et c'est pas bon non alors
que la sauvetage arrête pas là j'y
reviens tu peux montrer ou pas le truc
de la finale je peux revenir maintenant
6 4 il faut essayer un deuxième pion qui
peut jouer des cinq des cinq tours et
font un travail guinea alors déboursé
2,5 ou devant cédé 5 et toi et tu auras
tu mêles attend derrière et tu vas jouer
deux contre un et ça ça va gagner facile
et après juste un truc qui c'est un
marché peu autour c'est juste après un
truc dans la partie va dit non oui mais
ici
ok là il devait pas faire échec mais je
dessine mais il faut toujours garder
coup comme torres 6 mais peut être des
fois forment en fait yassa et blanc
imaginons que c'était plus bas ça
pourrait aider fois marché torréfié dans
le temps on pensait d'eux cette bâtisse
wilaya échec si le roi était plus bas
qu'en avec le rôle d un être humain
ouais mais bon il faut juste savoir tant
réussi c'est une idée qui existe dans
ces finales inquiète beau sauvetage bien
jouer alouettes baba alors à temps peut
on peut suivre
on peut se faire un délire c'est de
suivre les leaders mance et expo
expo 63 qui est leader et une banane
verte mais on l'a vu l'autre jour c'est
une canne jim lee ouais je trouve plein
qu'attend formaté de liens le lien du
club à mais peut-être que j'ai me
peut-être que jenny l'autre club
aujourd'hui j'ai mis le club cherche
comme en fait ôter je fais j'ai dû faire
une erreur les gars
ah désolé c'est moi qui ai fait une
erreur ouais pas mal non ok parce que je
suis sur plusieurs clubs
je vais aller vous chercher sa multi
club ouais ouais ouais en fait j'ai dû
oublier de changer de fer désolé les
gars il doit falloir être sur ce club là
vraiment désolé et je suis super désolé
les gars bon ça je trouve que c'est
juste que fofana ya tellement de menus
et appelle mans 2-2 moyen de se planter
celui un des plus jeunes gens seuls oui
mais ça va venir
ok c'est des finales au carreau cannes
ça va pour le noir mais il faut faire un
peu attention parce que telle plongée
c'est tfc reçoit un peu fun ouais en
général qui fait 1 3 roger pour un 3 2
des échanges une tour et tu vas essayer
d'attaquer les faiblesses oui kevin
débordés kevin as-tu fait des vidéos
tuto pour des 600 à 800 jeux début je
n'ai rien vu sur youtube alors ouais je
peux t'envoyer en plus il ya les liens
dessous après je vais t'envoyer ça ça
peut servir à tous les gens qui débutent
au nid d avoir ça
non alors attends je vais je vais faut
que je trouve ça sinon question les gens
qui font dislike ce que c'est toujours
les mêmes
ouais je crois enfin j'espère en tout
cas je me plais à espérer que ce soit
toujours les mêmes rageux l'espace qu'en
fait on a toujours à peu près le même
nombre 5 6 2 puis 8 9 mois malin qui est
qui m'était et chaque fois je commentais
qui mettait entre hilarité st oui cela
saperait haye de votre d'autres
personnes a critiqué ouais tu peux aller
voir cette vidéo
pour les débutants et tu dois avoir dans
les liens en dessous oui mais voilà il
quatre vidéos l'un des quatre autres
vidéos et puis après c'est du coup ça tu
en as déjà 5 ha ça fait cinq vidéos ont
tous fait déjà six heures après tu
pourras fouillé par toi même
moi je like est distincte jamais j'ai la
femme like bleiker gamine second quoi
les blancs bien joueurs les blancs bien
joué ils ont récupéré la colonne des le
roi n'aura est faible la case des six à
tomber trois menaces dame 17 en
récession c'est une conséquence les 10
miles sur l'album you tube
ouais ça permet de mieux référencer la
vidéo adresse connue en fait ils ont
fait ça exprès youtube parce que sinon
il y avait des gens à l'époque et ses
deux sacs et des vidéos en dislike en
massivement et du coup pour éviter que
les gens soient des rageux dislike
pourra pour embêter la juste part pas
par pure jalousie ou quoi ils ont fait
ce qu'ils écoutent le nom ne doit pas
écouter le stream à le bressan a c'est
possible le sujet dicté au delà quand je
tends g3 les essais de prendre un jeu
celle du prochain
bon il ya quand même vachement dieu mais
juste la dame en g2 attaqué rien là la
démarche des attaques à cinq
non pas un endroit à 8,1 17 tours b 8
500 cède 1.15 à quelle dame angers 2
s'avère beaucoup plus fort oui
wade eut maille manon les is nigh qu'en
fait du coup et ça ça fait grandir le
truc et c'est quelque chose de plutôt
utile à présent
on va voir mais par contre il est
tellement bien autant banane verte qui
devrait pouvoir la gagner et surtout il
le temps il ya une grosse différence
bien joué il devait faire ça pour jouer
de tourbe évite bien défendu wedde 1.5
tempo et il peut trouver à moscou un c4
me adama mais adam progressiste qui font
rage dans le tennis j'en ai jamais fait
de ma vie dont personne n'a pas émis six
heures 6 heures maso non mais kevin joue
vraiment tennis moi je suis chaud enfin
la sphère mangez pas joué ouais mais tu
y as joué à la main droite et que j'ai
fait un court de tennis avec maso je
suis allé à son club la primerose tu es
là où il ya tout et ça un enfant adam 1
827 c'est sûr attention à ne pas prendre
leur temps pour prendre aux apprentis on
prend voit ses sets et il ya les pions
qui sont fixés ça gagne ouais mais
fait-on prend 17 voitures réfléchit on
essaie de sa bande ont eu sept ans
débute imparable c'est pas faux nbc
blenders il n'a pas d'adversaire mais
jamais deux fois à bas essaye de mettre
un refresh sur la page alors j'aurai
jamais fait ça même si ça marche je
rajoute on prend 2,7 et j'attendrai le
problème en fait de bananes vertes c'est
qu'ils regardent beaucoup mais stream et
du coup il se met à jouer comme moi et
moi j'aurais fait ça m'est tombé ou
d'être con vas-y fais voir un truc au
coude avant mais c'est peut-être qu'on
parce que sa maman si je faisais un
grossiste au lieu de roide et 6 non mais
ah oui déjà ok sauf qu'ils rome et 3g 5
g 5 y avait quoi
5 as-tu affaires b5 et c5 est le truc
c'est le montrer c'est qu'en fait je
peux faire à g7 tu dois faire bref cette
c6 h3c 7h cette dame et vam échec et je
chauffe et le pion ben on va quand même
jamais fait samedi mais oui ça gagne
donc là il suffit de mettre ton
adversaire il obligé de bouger le
plonger alors barbarian ici dit dans
cette zone il est connu masoe wayne on y
parle du mont fleuri et non mais je suis
pas que la sautée dix ans je suis
mauvais mais à mais je m'amuse d'un
barbarians il avait bien joué l'autre
jour là il lit bien à lyon je remette le
lien de la reina et je viens du club
d'aujourd'hui 120 joueurs c'est mieux
aux historiens
je me suis planté que la tonte le redis
pour ceux qui viennent d'arriver qui
veulent s'inscrire mais bon du coup et
c'est qu'on a les interclubs
on va faire des petits interclubs chasse
comme aussi nonchalant ben ça marche
comment un club qui s'inscrivent et il
va y avoir une valeur pas mal de clubs
d'infos je peux récupérer le lien une
nouvelle fois
ce que je vais arriver mais le truc que
libye viennent d'envoyer il a reçu aussi
des visions un truc attend genre à
chercher le lien de samy sac à plein de
bien en ce moment et du coup à ses
cheveux d'humour ses poches profondes
sur la sur quatre ans des clubs un shu
donc ça va être intéressé n'hésitez pas
à écrire un mail à samy à moi c'est pas
un poisson d'avril c'est écrit le
premier et donc si vous voulez nous
filer f1 finalement je voulais
participer l'a en fait ce que du coup il
ya comme ça marche y créent leur équipe
ouais et après du coup on a un peu
changé apparemment fera que huit joueurs
de chaque équipe qui s'affrontent à
plein bien prise à 8,17 m 88e défendu la
baisse et rescrit nice est complètement
gagnant la difficulté pour réaliser des
trucs avec d'autres streamers a déjà
essayé de faire la petite difficulté
c'est de la langue c'est la langue ouais
c'est quand tu veux faire un truc avec
d'autres stream a en fait tu vas être
invitée sur leur stream et faire un truc
mais le truc c'est qu'il y en a qui
parlent français d'autres qui parlent
anglais quoi donc c'est pas évident je
fais de mieux qu'en 2008 où mais bon
j'ai fait des trucs avec d'autres
streamer j'étais sur le stream d'apps au
delà il ya quoi il ya deux trois jours
donc ça m'arrive de passer sur d'autres
sur d'autres stream
l'on comprend à peu près l'anglais
aujourd'hui wen en fait c'est une
chienne en français c'est pas pour faire
des blitz à la même chose en anglais
face c'est quoi l'intérêt en fait le muc
y attends j'ai vu deux civils et aux
coups d'avancé à gagner juste bon après
c'est comme communion ouais mais
pourtant on va finir trop loin ça marche
non pour faire de 1.286 plus rapide à la
normale je pars un jour le classement
tabou bull madoff ski expérimentée qui
dit que c'est des pleurs de feurs de
faim oui c'est facile
cette finale elle est bien simple heures
de cours d'ailleurs ya que deux pleurs
que je connais ouais là je pense que la
key2key détroit
oui la gaffe et il ya des fleurs
différentes fleurs de quand tu l'as
change
ouais c dont il vient attaquer des trois
fourchettes
allez c'est fou mais maintenant il fait
aussi un mais pourquoi il a fait baisser
ces fous qui rate hui ça rate beaucoup à
ce niveau là encore le petit jeu
tactique la plus grave c'est l'heure de
changement ça mais là je pense qu'un
échange la couche et quelle est la place
avec voudrait manger à mon avis elle
dormait la réveiller pour la changer
avant d'allaiter
ça m'a l'air d'être compliqué mais dis
toi que quand c'est à 2h du mat et ya un
babyphone tentent ensemble le genre dix
fois plus fort cette race revient à s'en
rendent fous ne manquant c'est la tienne
je pars ça me rend fou
d'affaires qui a aidé 4.3 tueur à nantes
et ses freins
j'étais sûr c'était sur l'accueil
c'était sur notre site rond jeunes c'est
le seul qu'on n'a pas vue du top
ouais un exercice et en plus qui vient
de démarrer sa partie contre gilles m
on n'a pas jamais vu aussi ce que vous
avez contre un conseil qui s'améliore en
finale mais apprends moi je pense au
début déjà apprendre les finales
théorique simple elles tomberont les
plus basiques le pion en est sûr de me
savoir la gagner ouais elles mêmes les
finales de fou simple coup de couleurs
opposées enfin regarder un peu toutes
les finales basiques de tout quoi déjà
tu fais tout ça et quand on connaît
actuellement toutes les finales basique
déjà par coeur
ça te va donner un feeling ya pas que ça
c'est que des fois on fait en partie tu
peux dire mais ça je ne sais pas si ça
gueule d'un coup tu te prends la tête
soit tu calcules tu calcules parce
qu'ils jouent tous les cas j'en sais
rien mais si tu le sais en fait ça peut
t'aider vachement bien ouais ça mettra
la pression quand vous regardez désolé
pète à goalball et c'est dommage tête a
raté une fourchette
c'était pas de chance c'est une belle
offre au delà les noirs sont un peu dans
le dur
ces jolies feuilles de khat d'un match
cats et que les coûts jolie en fait mais
à la fin tu as donné ta paire de fou ton
et chute à la casse des cinq ont le même
s'il aime blanc peuvent par auquel je
pense qu'ils sont bien j'ai coupé son ba
oui oui comme si vous pouvez les gars de
couper son canton à l'iso partir ne fait
pas une et rick hansen
ouais elle femme au zoo et rick hansen
je n'ai pas aidé les joueurs vont ils se
trouvent qu'ils jouent tous les coups
qui dit mais non mais en fait le truc
avec eric sur ce truc là en fait c'était
pas le fait qu'il ait aidé qu'il était
dommage
non mais il n'a pas compris le truc
parce qu'il dit c'est normal de faire ça
juste les gens en on écoute pas non mais
en fait c'est pas le fait que c'est pas
sa réaction à chaud et tout moi que j'ai
trouvé un peu dommage après je m'en fout
hein c'est qu'il soit pas juste excusé
dire désolé les gars si j'ai des c'était
pas volontaire
je pense que ça aurait été un peu à
propose de dire j'ai pas fait exprès
j'ai aidé les gars et un truc comme ça
et pas de dire non j'ai des personnes
c'est pas vrai tu vois ça arrive en live
on a chaud et où tu fais des conneries
et moi moi pareil tu vois tu te rends
pas compte ça va vite c'est juste après
coup de pas avoir juste reconnu tu vois
me trouvais ça un peu dommage ne veut
pas dire juste désolé les gars ça s'est
passé comme ça c'était pas c'est pas
dans l'idée de ce que je voulais faire
et puis voilà et puis c'est juste les
blancs de voix jeu pour des caches qu'on
s'est simplement je prends air france
n'est pas si clair ce que je peux mais
le cahier sur rêve cet effet mme chirac
et après je ne fais pas ça j'aime pas la
structure est non il s'était rien passé
gravats qu'eric c'était un match d'une
compétition de chasse comme entre
communautés et puis on ne devait pas on
avait les consignes de pas aidé les
joueurs ne pas dire de coûts donc moi je
commente et de mon côté je disais pas
les coûts pour nos gars et eric y
commentait de manière très active et
comme moi j'aurais voulu le faire en
fait mais je me retenais eric il a juste
pas pensé du coup c'est son nom
ouais ouais il faut absolument qu'ils
savent qu'ils jouent ça à chaque fois
qu'ils aient les coups gagnants et les
gars du coup 5,6 secondes après j'ai
joué le coup et donc du coup on avait un
peu gueulé en disant ouais face c'était
un peu interdits dans les règles et où
es tu
et je comprends qu'il soit à laisser
emporter par par le drive du truc juste
après sa réaction c'était plutôt dire en
mode web non c'est normal ce que j'ai
fait alors qu'ils se trouvent que qui
les fait involontairement je comprends
après ça aurait été cool de dire juste
excusez moi et puis la verrait enfin ya
toujours rien dit pas si grave
c'est pas grave du tout oui oui c'est un
peu malade mais juste le truc était
maladroit c'est tout et c'était pas
grave s'était marié en question c est
comment lire un livre c'est une bonne
question
oui mais ça dépend quel type de livre si
c'est par exemple les mères partie d'un
joueur c'est bien essayé de trouver les
coûts de réfléchir voilà après avoir
joué le coup d'essayer de comprendre
comment la mecque en est venu à trouver
de bons coups mais les mettre sur un
échiquier y faire un bilan pas chercher
vous les regardez apprécié d'apprendre
d'être comprendre si c'est les finales
je pense la première fois il suffit
juste de regarder
et après s'il leur faire tout seul ou
avec quelqu'un c'est lui le mieux qu'on
veut travailler final c'est à 2 vous
étudiez la théorie chacun de votre côté
et après vous vous la jouer des lacs et
de couleurs se parent est ça le truc que
j'ai jamais fait j'étais seule la city
seul ce que je compte leur dis pas parce
qu'on met pour une finale alors dit
défend bien oui mais si après tu arrives
à la gagner oui bien sûr mais c'est au
contraire ce même mieux me rappelle que
j'avais fait un truc marrant je suis pas
très bon tu es dans la finale théorique
surtout à l'époque ce n'était pas très
bon j'avais un jour fait un cours sur
flocons d'or est une des finales
théorique mes parents une des plus dures
ouais et avec mon élève qui était 2003
et du coup j'avais pas préparé le court
et donc on regarde la théorie ensemble
et on se le blitz et c'était vos rides
pour lui ce qu'il organisait pas vrai
que temps fou et je gagne à chaque fois
la victoire je la connaissais pas mais
je sais pas il me semble qu'il ya un
truc qui l'avaient pas compris où c'est
déjà le machisme dans la ja pas capté 8
à la place
kébé 4 oui mais je pense qu'il n'a pas
vu mais y'avait kébé 4 mais je pense qu
il se dit que c'est vrai que ma tour et
2 km et jusqu'à ses cinq intermédiaires
et ouais tu mêleront des six après tu
prend la fuite et ouvrent la colonne des
donc des dominos ça tu prends et des
quatre juges seront dessinés un peu
moche il a carrément non non je pense
qu'il faut pas moi je suis maintenant à
will est plein à temps que les blancs
abandonné à il est tombé autant avec les
bancs en mer ne rêve en fait ces deux
livrets et duvets et goûter j'ai pas non
et oui oui alors il calcule et moi ça
m'est déjà arrivé ça tu calcules tu te
présenter calcules tu oublies cette
ferrari parle il faut qu'il a écrit l'un
d'eux s'est dit dégoûté de deux fois que
je tourne c'est horrible et c'est
dommage que de la partie était pas mal
mais s'illustre en plus de dresser c'est
pas facile on me demande d'arrêter une
fois qu'ils seront beaucoup tu n'as tu
jamais du mal quand tu repasses sur un
vrai chic et en fait je repasse jamais
sur un vrai chic et carlos parlant du
coup c'est pratique mais moi j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup plus de mal de
calculer sur un andy c'est une question
d'habitude
ouais ouais mais ouais pour moi ça
pouvait être un preuve un moment le
passage mais comme tu veux utiliser les
échiquiers trois djs comme s'ils sont
bien mal regarde je vois fantastique
l'échiquier 3v danse à apprendre
quelques secondes pour le savent à peu
faire planter de leyde nom magnifique
non c'est matt major prince est un
exemple j'étais là c'est parti en cours
non mais oh regarde sans paniquer 3g de
chasse comme franchement honnêtement moi
ici ici pour les noirs fait les jeux f5
ouais c'est hyper important en fait faut
arrêter l'avancée là du point f sinon
ton roi est trop faible
fall a préparé un triptyque là dessus on
peut importe mais l'échiquier 3d bien ou
pas bref trois fois de suite au 1
et du coup tu peux voir les parties
comme ça ouais tu peux tu peux même
jouer comme ça ça donne dix heures de
jeu les plus riches et pas aux attentes
moi je te dis ça pour t'aider 1 je ne me
fais plus aucune illusion
honnêtement je trouve l'échiquier 3d de
chasse comme assez bien réussi pour de
la fausse 3d y avait lieu de 3,1 me
latour en prison en egypte n'a pas l'air
emballé par l'échiquier 3 v mais je sais
pas si je serai ça m'aiderait fruits
prendrai jamais la tour de la torah 8,7
à bout non c'est pas tabou ce pack naboo
les gens ça pique les yeux moi j'aime
pas du tout l'échiquier en 3d
personnellement j'ai vraiment du mal
déjà en vrai j'ai plus de vagues en 2d
sur sur un ordi c'est encore pire mais
je trouve que pour un échiquier 3d est
assez réussie parce que j'en ai vu
d'autres
auparavant quand j'utilise elle est
programmée à 15 20 ans et c'était
vraiment horrible under way exactement
fou c'est un rouage un fou prend le trou
trop sexy tu prend 1,3 trop vite qui
aura food & gamble va pas se le prendre
mort ou un chat tu prends ça va guinée
laitiers 3d tabou nous dit on et dansent
pas de tabou
le problème sur un vrai chic et pour les
débutants c'est qu'on peut rater les
coups illégaux vrai mais si les de
lörrach le coût devient légal mais au
contraire ce même bien c'est plus drôle
rêver après il arrive même que des
joueurs proratat des coups illégaux et
mathieu n'a femmes deux domaines par
exemple un petit rock illégal en
week-end mais ce qui compte c'est que si
le voit c'est matt au coude a pris
puisque le losc devait bouger au panama
crois qu'elle était gagnante mais ça l'a
perturbé on l'a pas vue dit il
j'ai un groupe comme prénom génie bien
ok c'est un jouet théoriquement on
dirait un mais renvoie sa wii et le jeu
pouvait tomber 3 mais ses adhérents ton
mais font voler les blindes mais je sens
que c'est hyper important
ouais je vais faire ça quand même mais à
ça ça ressemble plus à un anti mayrand
un tour hier trois sont impartiaux
mais l'idée est bonne mais faucheux cinq
ans fait un jour mais au casse-tête pas
si clair si les noms avec ses 5 ça peut
être très dangereux donc allégé 4 f 2,8
kg 4 h3
j'ai pas vu ni des maternelles et b6 et
c 5 après tu peux laisser statu quo quoi
au moins tu as gagné la casa je crois tu
empêches tourache trois fois tombé
retour en france que ton âge pauli 17e
saint qui achètent que tu ne te guette
oui hachette va plus être tabou est ce
que tu as comme compte organiser un
petit toit avec de gros joueurs
il ya des trucs je crois en préparation
robin je sais pas quoi exactement
mais je crois qu'il ya un truc
en préparation après je sais pas trop ce
qu'ils vont faire mais je crois qu'il se
concentre plus sur les joueurs amateurs
de quoi pendant jazz comme ils vont
amener plus se concentrer sur les
joueurs amateurs pour 6 il va y avoir
des gros tournois sur czech comme celle
plus bref il faut faire les deux mais
c'est bien on attends chez toi ton
projet tu sais pourquoi où c'est tabou
alors non un truc que je peux déjà dire
c'est que c'est sûr à 100% qu'il y aura
des stream caritatif sur la chaîne
bitstream les 11 et 12 avril après le
format ce qui va se passer exactement ça
dépend encore des réponses de certaines
personnes mais il y aura forcément des
trucs qui seront faits le week end du 11
et du 12 pour les médecins donc à voir
après mathieu ton fera forcément partie
d'une manière x ou y
probablement j'espère comme anton ouais
non mais à plein de formats différents
qu'il ya même dans les trucs proposés
bas qui tu vois au delà du petit tour à
qu'on veut faire ou quoi il voulait
peut-être faire une petite heure de
partie pédagogique contre les médecins
lui un moment donné un accepter que les
médecins sur 10 sont à jouer qui avait
lieu 4 mais oui c'est une rayure pas
beaucoup de médecins sur la chaîne voilà
tous les gens qui sont au milieu
hospitalier mais sans quoi il a dit on
pourrait faire une petite heure deux
parties pédagogie contre eux tu as donc
il ya pas mal de petites idées parce
qu'en fait le truc de mai des 500 milles
et arrive à être sûr de deux semaines
entières donc il ya deux week-ends où on
pourra streamé pour par rapport à ça du
coup et donc on va voir
non mais c'est très bien de faire ça en
fait si tu fais pas là tu ne fais jamais
voilà vous les infirmières tous les gens
qui bossent dans le
de près ou de loin dans le système de
santé bien jouer bancaire français trop
c'était la même sans perdre l'aide sans
perdre une pièce c'est un peu con ce
qu'il pouvait pas reprendre lui tour
d'air ses comptes mais 5,3 gages mais
mais mais mais surtout les proctor avec
monsieur p soit 3 dans le premier tour
de mes parts on t'aura je te fais un
voeu des trois-tours h3c chercher ma
mère parce qu'il était gagnant laqué
blanc quasiment sûr pas on essaye
d'organiser un gros tournoi de toute
façon il ya et maxime aussi qui passera
par rapport à ça dans tous les cas on
peut je peux pas vous dire exactement ce
qui sera fait parce qu'on est pas sûr où
là il laisse rien
il a mis ce flic mais il y aura
forcément forcément des choses qui
seront faites
est ce qu'il y aura une kawa il va fin à
ces médecins sans frontières monsieur
pessoa qui va faire une cagnotte
spéciale sur sûr je sais pas si tu
utilises tipi je sais pas comment ils
font mais en fait l'argent ira
directement à médecins sans frontières
dont il y aura deux de ses primes dans
d'autres sports
il y aura plein de gens qui
participeront à sai c'est un truc
internationale qui sont en train de
monter
j'ai pas encore tous les détails c'est
pour ça que je parle un peu au
conditionnel puisque j'attends que les
confirmations mais c'est sûr à 99%
non mais ben écoute on fait ce qu'on
peut le truc c'est bon on en parle avant
le live nous on n'a pas de gros moyens
enfin moi j'ai pas de gros moyens
financiers je peux pas tuer la chaîne je
la fais gratuitement et on a un peu les
savait tout mais on peut pas on peut pas
avoir le top mondial pour faire des
tournois x ou y mais nous ce qu'on peut
faire c'est aider les gens quoi parce
que le dire dans un monde nouveau et je
ne veux leur dire et nos studios
ouais c'est ça non mais oui non mais
vous êtes complètement
donc on essaye de faire avec nos moyens
pour les gens
notes milieu qu'enfin entre guillemets
vous ne vous en avez peu a commenté de
parties de plus bas niveau
un peu mais objectivement ça peut vous
faire progresser donc c'est un peu le
but de la chaîne non content d'aider mon
nom mais c'est sympa en plus ce n'est
parti sympa non ya pas de match ça aussi
c'est de la merde ça prend 1,5
non là c'est sûr mais je pense tu prends
le tour je la tue chargement la merde
mais les gens oublient des fois c'est
quand tu es gagnant tu veux trop
optimisé c'est un peu mieux l'esquissé
ckpa de mattia pas le et chaque échec et
ce matin il a 19 secondes c'est pas si
simple
il ya peut-être prendre la nuit n'ont
pas assez pleutres oh c'est incroyable
c'est pleutres non mais juste du fait de
jouer four b3 de tête n'ont d'ailleurs
trouvé trop plein art et 3 pas mal ce
que tu aurais fait un compresseur bon
achat taurin et qui savent a gagné assez
facilement à cacher mais xeni via
pleutre ah ouais donc on les a tous vu
des premiers livres lyon n'a pas vu mais
ils ont en diamants ouais
puis un plus si je peux encore tombé sur
un mot gré vous avez la première ça
ouais
en plus il commencera contre cyril lafon
plus ainsi alors qu'on n'a pas vu
aujourd'hui
oui enfin ce sont ces lieux de pouvoir
tout commenté enfin les échecs c'est
beau le haut niveau mais il faut
comprendre qu'il ya pas que le haut
niveau mais après c'est important je
faisais un raisonnement par l'absurde
avec fable au téléphone quand on se
parlait je suis on compare les des
parties de haut niveau de bas niveaux
gmail en fait c'est tout est très
relative parce que j'y parle encore vlad
les regards des parties de gala 2004 il
est là il rigole tout le temps et en
fait c'était toujours bas niveau par
rapport à quelqu'un si karl ça nous
regarde les parties de vlad il va
essayer incroyable comment est-il si mal
joué ici alpha 0 bah oui c'est toujours
le nul d'un hôte toujours le fort de
quelqu'un donc faux je pense qu'il faut
garder l'humilité et surtout aimer les
échecs pour la beauté tuant des partis
comme ça c'est hier avec rabon a vu
dessus ou avec sami avant-hier il y
avait deux super finale qu'on s'est mis
un peu à toucher parce que j'étais
vraiment mal tu vois des genres des
études est en fait tu peux trouver de la
beauté dans des parties de n'importe
quel niveau
pas toujours un moment tu peux avoir une
phase de jeu jolie ou des idées joly
après - n'ont jamais entraîné donc en
plus expliquer avec des mots simples
quelque chose s'est pas donné la fin
c'est pas donné à tout le monde sait que
c'est pas si simple en fait et je pense
que c'est important que des gens
d'apprendre pourquoi un truc est simple
pour nous il pour vous n'est pas
forcément pour l'instant mais ça peut le
devenir
il faut que quelqu'un vole et si
personne ne vous le dit des fois c'est
dur de remonter la chose
nous on a eu des entraîneurs ou alors on
a beaucoup travaillé seul et je dois
dire qu'il ya des choses qui peuvent
venir plus instinctivement même centre
100 contre le dise oui mais il ya de
tout enfin combien de personne n'aurait
pu deviner à grand'maître mais juste
saison pages aux échecs en son sein moi
je parlais pas d'échec dans ma phrase
c'était une phrase à double sens
d'accord j'aime bien laisser un blanc
assez gênant après genre de trucs non
mais je serais déjà bien je vais garder
c'est le petit blanc dans la calèche il
a mille formé cette spa terim les miens
aussi sme
mais du coup il a servi les échines kof
ouais et noir
cavaillé ou trois jeux que je vous
prends pas ce qu'est prend feu gad bien
à tort qu'il se fait battre par les 1200
du quotidien se passe peut-être le même
1200 qu'ils battent les jours en fait
c'est le mec tous les jours une craie
son pseudo pour veut contre lui par 1200
c'est ce qui a aidé car si pas contre
sedan nantes est moins bien non c'est
moins bien parce que les blancs offert à
troy un peu 9 4 les noms tout plan potes
ça va bien dallas et c'est tout ce que
je fous prêtres dont crée toujours pour
égaliser
tu vas essayer d'atteindre genre tu peux
mettre thorens et 6 d'avancé 7 et a tant
fait défaut des positions comme ça fait
que leur poser c'est toujours un peu
mieux c'est chiant
j'en ai gagné une belle une fois ya
longtemps pour en espagne comme ça
j'avais pioncer de il avait deux des
pions a6b 5 et je pourrais la montre un
jour à l'été pédagogie d'après
polissonne entraîneur au niveau
supérieur oui/non face il ya donc là il
ya c'est simple tu les meilleurs du
monde ils ont bien des entraîneurs et
ils sont pas mûrs que c'est après des
fois on sait puis qui sait mur tu as
d'ailleurs qui m'a raconté ça il m'a dit
il avait pris un entraîneur d'ailleurs
c'était xavier parmentier il y avait
utilisé le principe
imaginons j'ouvre un livre je regarde
une partie je sais pas si la partie et
bien je sais pas encore exactement je
dois chercher
donc si un entraîneur me dit tu mets
cette position où tu réfléchis rien que
ça s'arrête de salaire c'est lui qui a
fait le travail en amont lui connaît la
solution
il a vu la partie du coup il peut te
dire si ça vaut le coup de la chercher
ou pas il peut dire chercher un coup
regardé une partie en c1 on dit tu
serais un élite 2 secondes en mettez
plus ou moins seconde en en quelque
sorte à trop gelé a été lynché pu
s'entretenir selon ma femme je seconde
entre eux entre autres
j'ai été très heureux tu rentres tu es
là tu vas à la la la tête c'est le
commentaire du jour quoi même pas eu la
seconde
entre autres je vous venez chez secondes
et bacrot pendant deux ans il ya
quelques années quand ils étaient 27 24
ans fois qu'il faut que tu réussisses a
rajouté le rire gras et et ce sera
parfait contre berriane qui veulent le
sol tôt - ouais mais tous les jours il
faut barbarian tiens regarde peut rien
qu'à sion à boeing il a un peu loin il
est 6e mais c'est un habitué
ça fait plaisir qu'un sans limite on
tourne rafale admire qu'est ce que ça va
moi est ce que j'ai déjà eu envie de
seconde à un joueur j'ai pas niveau
monsieur pelé soir sur tout ça moi le
problème
[Musique]
chacun son boulot on est allé dire
mathieu a été coupée bon j'ai des fois
les neuf de calais f17 ça peut paraître
bizarre mais c'est pour forcer les gens
à dire quelque chose aux sondes pour
bientôt si j'ai un niveau vraiment nul
mais je suis sûr qu'en analyse je serai
correct ça arrive d'être un meilleur
analyste que joueur est-ce que tu
connais un certain damien ah bah oui
j'espère bien on connaît tous d'avenir
non doit mieux encore un toit mieux que
moi d'ailleurs
green it and weight à j'imaginais j'ai
travaillé pour le film de cannes quand
il était président j avais alors du coup
cannes belleville je recommande
d'ailleurs j'ai jamais vécue j'ai vécu à
nice et j'ai vécu à mougins
bon c'est pas loin je recommande non
j'aime pas trop sérieux ouais ça c'est
un truc de ouf
bah en fait c'est bien l'été quand il ya
du monde il fait beau mais après juste
c'est plaisant la croisette où sa mère
est la ville en elle même le vieux canal
web le centre c'est sympa fin après moi
je suis né ici c'est difficile de juger
ouais c'est comme nice nice et des
points tellement beau touristique et
tout mais après moi je vivais derrière
la guerre c'est pas tirer à moi j'aime
panis bon non plus après le vieux nice
quand tu croyais moi j'aime pas trop de
génie sont plus fins laissez moi
tranquille note dhamir j'ai de nouvelles
un peu de temps il va bien ou pas
d'ailleurs
un mieux mais ça va mieux on sait que le
but des petits problèmes
c'est bien c'est bien c'est que ça fait
plaisir d'entendre ça met d'ailleurs en
été chérie tu préfères chartres à
mathieu peut-être ils préfèrent chartres
je veux que cyril lafon sueur mais mon
but c'est jeudi paktia c'est pas bien
mais juste j'allais trois font un nom
aurait été d'ailleurs c'est pas sûr que
j'y retourne le top 12 j chrono en main
par mois ces championnats de france dont
je le tente douce je suis sûr que ça
aura pas lieu mais mais le championnat
de france je suis loin d'être sûr il ya
tellement de choses qui commencent à
être annulé en juillet août à nice et à
ballack les caisses
il ya eu des petits prêts d'argent oui
j'ai jeune cheveux de france cette année
j'ai fini 5e pas fini 5e et tu joues tu
negro qualifier c'est un métier un cas
de figure con que je peux si je te le
racontent eux on a fini 5e ex-aequo à 2
et 5 ou ailier de mettre la perte dans
leur règlement les cinq qualifiés mais
j'ai exactement marraine 9 nuls avec
scolaire on a exactement la même
dépendance et du coup à la perche je
serai devant mais la perte n'est pas
écrit dans le règlement du coucou je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils vont faire ce qu'ils
sont en garde dès que ça y est on est
six à ils ont oublié de rentrer ça dans
règlement
du coup certains parce que j'ai
tellement ce que fait l'air ou moisson
n'est pas prêt s'installe on fait ce
qu'on a je pense qu'ils vont prendre les
deux mais c'est pas sur un mille fois
son nom ménage un j'aime pas non plus
prometteurs étaient irrattrapables mais
sait jamais après l'agent soit j'ai rien
contre j'adore les mecs du club
c'est un peu ma région c'est pas trop en
fonctionnement à ces pratiques mais de
là à y aller tous les 6 mois non
après j'avais été champion de france à
agen j'arrive bons souvenirs mais oui
par principe je n'aime pas chez lagune
je suis très bien fourchette mais c'est
pas si clair ce qui à la casse des six
encore à faire d'un mode aux quatre
virages mais les noirs sont entrés dure
depuis longtemps mais ils commencent à
revenir impôts de mai barbarian je sais
pas comment il fait et mystifie les gens
il a vraiment beaucoup de mauvaises
positions qu'ils retournent la dernière
fois il y avait des gaffes en un il
donne une pièce les gars là prennent pas
légal ils font des mises clic et les
fils des dames je sais pas il doit il
doit avoir des grigris cas les décisions
d'un média important à ce qu'il connaît
par bahreïn et dans son club de maisons
alfort
il joue quoi ton point et ferons cette
frange et 6 ça m'a l'air très fort il
pouvait pas jouer simple ou coup de vent
peut-être qu'ils pouvaient quel point
cette frange évident qu'avec huit tours
paris vii c'est logique aux siens mais
moi j'aurai bientôt fait en deux points
[Musique]
il ya une qualité de plus en fait un
milieu trop de pions la vie je balance
on en a
si les gens veulent rester anonymes s'il
veut balancer son nom après il le fera
mais qui barbarian mais il est mis sa
photo où nous on sait pas si c'est lui
quoi ils seront vingt sept étaient tous
reprend j'ai deux tours pranger de un
gpu droit j'avais pas vu non plus
pour répondre bah oui mais simplement y
avait non donc il a bien joué mais
barbares nc10 laquelle par contre tu
peux nous dire un peu ça a tranché l'eau
h face à ça tu peux nous dire que c'est
pas moins l'une d'un g5 encore il survit
2150 franchement il joue pas mal hein
c'est un médecin ce soir ouais n'hésitez
pas à maisons alfort si vous aussi vous
avez envie d'essayer notre notre
compétition là faut que vous incrire
faut que vous vous inscriviez pardon
assez rapidement mais elle est sauvée
nombreuses oui d'après du salar en
charge chez tmg cinq échecs n'ont ni
même d'un transit de ce qu'on voit bien
qu'elle serait là serait la tuile mais
même en moi un des mecs de ses impôts je
vois pas l'intérêt en plus d'être monté
toute façon non au nom d'un f2 c max
mais la gestion du temps est très
mauvaise de j'ai remarqué beaucoup oui
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec toi
moi après je suis un peu trop long perso
quand je joue mais à mais les gens mon
profil l'oeil sont trop rapide juste
parce que ça sort là toi de perdre avec
deux minutes à la prendre des risques a
noté le roi m6 cavaillé f5
c'est juste matin mais vous voyez quand
on vous disait que voir des parties de
joueurs plus faible ça peut être aussi
sympa c'est que ce genre de position là
nous on les voit jamais normalement
quasiment du coup on a laissé vaut quand
même le roi là qui finit par monter à la
volée s'est pas complètement faux et oui
en plus cons sur internet de cavale f5
maintenant des ventes ou la dame serait
parti le cavalier i te couvre la case h4
c'est le match juste way n'a pas tord à
7 il ya cavaliers comme j'ai eu deux
matches mais ça va relancer le suspense
dans le tournoi parce que du coup mot
grec peut éventuellement revenir aux 63
ouais ça ça peut revenir sur l'iss qui
perd du temps six cavaliers relation n'a
pas vu non non mais il est un peu loin
un matelas gamin il ya plus que expo
maugrée follow you barbarian ouais bah
oui au niveau des points mais s'est bien
défendu une nouvelle fois mais pas de
gains non non tu dois juge de la finale
tu bouffes h ou dit vêtu pousse-t-on qui
ont des seins
moi je vous ferai hc part sinon tu
bouges ton qui ont retenu fait faux elle
non j'aime pas en fait grâce à genk 1-2
donc l es5 leur tour ils proposent il
faut f5
elle menace d'abord à 7
ces cheminots la tourette 7 carine
séchaud de night 11,6 du coup il a fait
n'importe quoi m cadets player juge
jouer la finale pousser les pions mais
tours et des tours fc qui perd la donne
incroyable oh la la c'est con quand même
qu'ils aient mystifie ce thème est
choisi par marianne et mystifie à
l'adversaire et tamara lot
teyssen prendrait cinq matches tu vas
voir cette folle ma tondeuse web
c'est pourquoi après bravo barbarian
fixé par rapport au tournoi on avait
envie de et maugréant puisque a perdu
contre cyril ou ou si les loups voilà ça
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas vue mais trois
cent mille est loin il a dû arriver tarn
ouais mais là ça veut dire que dans tous
les cas barbarian il a tous points
d'avance il marche sur le tournant en
fait complètement un plus il a un strike
the district par district web en anglais
c'est strict la str eux à carhaix
pourquoi ils perdent et forcément ça va
parce qu'elle était enfermée
parce que le roi était enfermée en fait
ce qu'il aurait dû faire après d'alger 2
c'est juste bêtement de rendre fou dès
cette année pourquoi pousser le pion
l'autre con ce processus est le pion est
inarrêtable
de toute façon dû aux deux pions avec
l'aide du roi et des pièces homme se
combinant vignes mais même au pire tu
mourras je te pousse des on peut voir un
peu nicolas du coup puisque là on puisse
y joue contre eux exposent 33 donc c'est
un duel de haut de tableau ça c'est
bizarre cette fois donc bien content que
ce nom ouais c'est comme le début car au
grain
[Musique]
donc il reste qu'ils jouent une attaque
stonienne en premier ce n'est pas idiot
non surtout on glisse parce que tu
connais tu es d'un premier coup bref
accueil ces quatre noms de gagner tu
gagnes pas une pièce un peu bizarre il a
mis du temps à prendre l'option d'écart
c'est moi ce qui me sert à turin truc
qui m'a halluciné quand même ces deux
c'est de voir que quand tu mets des
partis comme ça des arènes et qui fait
jouer des gens du coin mais là je serais
retourné aux 4 cuil il avait un complice
très très disparates en fait sur les
gens faire des grosses erreurs well as
s'est retourné c'est là le fou des cinq
euros la suite tu préfères maintenant
d'un match 4 fellag à l'accueil et qui
s'y passe et il n'y avait pas non plus
quand on se quitter sur ces trois là je
vous prendrai 4 qui épaississent assez
bien joué positionnelle la case des
seins nus du coup la part alain prévient
revient la faute 3,7 et 4,1 d'un bébé
tron il ya eu six femmes mais si tu
joueras suite je voulais je descends je
comprends faut 3 et au moins j'ai gardé
les jaunes qui ont mené les bonnes
pièces blessure qui avait pris les
prisons bessette et surtout et trois au
moins est allé bonne pièce tu vas faire
tourner pour mieux rendre un pion que
souffrir à la casse des quatre pour le
gard avec cet état là il a donné être 4c
chu
merci c'est quoi le lien les potes alors
à temps pour mettre les liens mars et ça
c'est pour les clubs et pour le lien
dutronc asselah mais c'est avec le club
de chasse comme france - le lien pour
les interclubs du push les remis ce g5
bien jeu pour jouer 4 way to reprend
donne la qualité leur one blanc et c'est
tellement horrible je veux qu'elle 5 et
hk toqué on est quatre
on se prendrait pas autrement
réussissent aussi non oui car quoique je
crois quand même en jeu mais le caire
ayant f7 après ça reste une pièce 1 en
fait c'est quoi ta ce point comme si une
organisation c'est une fédération c'est
une société en fait la signant un but
lucratif à but lucratif complètement
nous son peuple ne sont pas à plaindre
ribeauville peu de ce que je regarde les
vidéos de mathod genish non je connais
mais pour moi c'est un petit peu dur ses
coûts c'est un gars qui fait des bonnes
vidéos par ailleurs assez courtes sur
des baux jolie partie donc bref d'échec
des chèques ouais donc c'est cool après
pour nous que ce soit pour toi pour moi
le problème c'est qu'il est vraiment pas
assez fort et donc c'est pas très
intéressant mais c'est très intéressant
pour des gens qui veulent voir des
belles parties et se faire une culture
pressé bien est ce que moi je suis
salarié de cette entreprise à temps
plein non du coup déjà la moitié des
trucs que tu fais c'est billy sport plus
celle du streaming be string c'est une
autre société mais ça n'a aucun rapport
quel est le secret c'est qu'il veut et
et vidéos sur leur site
ouais mais ça c'est le plus notoire de
partenariat d'ailleurs qu'autre chose
mais non sans rien à voir si tu faisais
que du jazz comme point fr oui
[Musique]
malheureusement valises tornade von dach
oignons c'est super triste je la
connaissais pas bien mais je l'avais
déjà vu des montées l'avait déjà joué
assez triste à des fins auto pour en
rognant ça peut être facile à vivre
non vous avez pas dans push mail et il
part active à l'arrivée j'ai plein de
trucs belle fille d'un saut avec les
stars ça allait moins deux millions de
voitures
on notera en larmes imminent en harmonie
oui en arménie je croyais revan et je
crois je suis pas sûr l'un se nomme guy
drouin
on était de la torah qatar seul raymond
way g4g 3 ça refroidit en plus talent
fou qui est le pion à la fin qu'est ce
tu peux faire nom est roger 4
c'est un peu bizarre plus à l'aise dès 4
mais oui c'est bien ça te bats il fait
au plan b car ils perdent ajoutant g4
france bécasse provoquerait et du coup
avant et ça veut dire que expo ah ouais
ça va jouer là là c'est une partie
importante pour l' expo dont une gagnée
quand il veut pas forgé katsuni j'ai
bien gagné son jeu mais je pense que si
l'échangé détour par contre ça va être
ok ça va continuer de gagnant et sept
mois je trouve qu'ils se complique quand
même largement l'avenir
ouais c'est qu'ils aiment bien guillaume
rhinos calme très gagnant mais il s'est
compliqué la vie
après c'est ma tente de nous gaver la
justice à la fin ou 5 5 il a gagné du
coup aurait du coup ça nous a gazés
venizia aussi qui est bien et il ya pas
mal de monde sur le banc on l'a vu lui
on a vu une fois non ouais on l'a vu une
fois on peut le revoir un peu si je t'ai
ligne ouais en plus ils vous mes limites
on va repasser et salue the war in the
world
bonjour à toi du coup c'est possible
pour les blancs ses positions mais bon
pour les 6 2 heures pour un an et on est
super nombreux sur le live aujourd'hui à
tant mieux combien on est 7 100 m
martial où tu imagines tu es pour
saint-etienne les materner ans conçu
pour bordeaux enfin fait de ma vie
pendant d'autres si je suis dans le dur
aussi bordeaux et hôtels en dur un vrai
moi je suis pour marseille je suis dans
le dur aussi la maison blanche je suis
dégoûté quoi enfin une saison tu joues
bien pourquoi on met le font sens pour
protéger le bd en fait t'as pas vraiment
bon coup pour protéger ses pour sa b3
tapas en vue d'affaiblir et des gondoles
parce que le fauga les ambitieux je
crois par contre il peut aussi durer que
quatre mois j'avais analysé les données
sur finul mais quelle idée de d'un
procès 3 tu peux vraiment le prendre
tout trois sets s'il faut c'est cette un
des six fils quand tu es qu'avaient les
deux dames devant 3 et après un report
de notre côté il ya des compenserait je
le rappelle exactement
j'haïs ça il ya quinze ans il ya vingt
ans quoi mais c'est jouable pour les
blancs mais tu es passé avec des
poussières résiduelles
en fait ça fait jouer une sorte de
benoni et est ce que les norvégiennes
benoni bla pas forcément mais 140 sur
youtube wat hu a même fait you tube ça
marche et moins les autres jours et
aujourd'hui du coup à moi y'a un truc je
te le dis à chaque fois je ne comprends
pas quand ça se cumulent les chiffres
gens là les 142 youtube qu'ils sont pas
infinies rage les cons en tulle et
comptent pas sur twitter
en général ou youtube honnêtement tu
t'en fiches un peu dans tout le nord
menace cavaillon 5 pour manger le var le
réseau phev 5
et s'il faut paris avocat français 4
donc il faut trouver un vent de quoi est
fait blanchir pas trop ce que moi je
ferai cavaliers de 5 à chaque prise il
faut être un bon je préfère maintenant
la vertu avec des gens qui posent des
questions sur youtube et où le csaj
avait pas ouvert des luttes et les 20 à
30 personnes sur 1 sur youtube au jour
il ya plus de monde on sait pas je sais
pas pourquoi en fait youtube pour le
live c'est vraiment mal mal organisés
bordelais de cette année la grande
époque c'est 99 donc plus tard de l'as
mandé 2009 gourcuff chamakh cavenaghi
chamakh il était bon un très altruiste
mais surtout avec gourcuff à l'époque où
il était juste hallucinant un laïc
perrine tourne pas une qualité d'un toit
il y aurait du jeu f4 avec lecavalier en
c'est ça qu'on appelle delà du pôle
montres et d'ailleurs c'est ça la
prophylaxie les noirs menacé cavalia 5
puis prise du fou aux coudes à vendre à
la presse dr bien le bon coup en fait tu
le trouves par analogie ctf 4 empêche
l'idée de vias ça c'est très important
en effet il faut comprendre l'idée de
verser beaucoup plus fils blessé pas et
il jouait tellement bien avec laurent
blanc entraîné un point c'était
hallucinant on va tendre fait une saison
parfaite
gerald des gens se rappellent pas ou
roupe de champion's league il ya bayern
event us j'ai plus la quatrième métier
et bordeaux fait premier son groupe
c'est par là nous ils font quarts de
finale où demi finales en battant lyon
1-0 lyon
huawei et en perd 11 points rouges de
planus qui est complètement inexistant
on les déchire les deux matchs si on
perd et à partir de là on perd la finale
de coupe de la ligue et le championnat
on avait dix points d'avancé à mi saison
et on perd explosion du club fath mois
selon je me rappelle de bordeaux c'est
surtout l'année où vous prenez un but à
la vous marqué à la 94e contre
entre paris et ça le sonic marseille moi
j'y crois pas du tout à ce qui prévaut
c'est 99
ouais mais moi j'y crois pas du tout à
ce but avait il est sûr qu'il a été
marqué non mais le but a été marqué mais
je suis sûr que paris le laisse marquer
il préférait que bordeaux gagne après
sur la saison c'était les deux équipes
méritaient de gagner
c'était genre de saison les deux équipes
sont monstrueuses comme leader olé bas
et moi c'est pour moi bordeaux en fait
et c'est un gars complètement nul en
plus qui le marque fernando simple non
c'était feindouno de mon avis bill et
jacinthe et justement il a joué à
chanter tunisiens de tous les temps par
les jeudis soirs du coup je déteste je
déteste cette histoire je suis supporter
des jardins à huawei quand bordeaux ils
ont battu milan il ya longtemps il était
au stade les autres 96
ouais bord dominant 3 euros que j'étais
au stade avec avait été décotées peup.pa
fin bat en finale on joue pas bien mais
c'est un hamac chaleur autour j'étais au
stade aussi une porte dans la pomme très
bien je des blancs ici d'ailleurs 1400
projets ont réussi un profil aussi ben
tu vois une équipe d aurélien un maccabi
haifa ok ça qu'elle était une bonne
équipe heures le maccabi haïfa dans un
moment privé surprise d'aller voir un
match pourri de tokyo six étaient
bordeaux plus jeune du club roumain
arrêt mais tu avais des clubs parfois
comme ça des pays de l'est ce qui sur
une saison j'ai un truc non même avant
c'était à l'époque de marseille tous à
l'étoile rouge belgrade c'était la
meilleure équipe du monde avec avec le
milan et marseille
comment ne pas parler du dynamo kiev qui
a appris à toute l'europe à faire le
caté nature est-ce que je joue au tennis
que j'ai un pull pas beau la whey
exactement raffarin académies ne devait
même pas qui a gagné ses huit sans
déconner c'est marrant non
je vais la faire partir un peu trop bien
pour jouer pour les blancs et si vite
c'est bizarre mais j aurais jamais pensé
je l'aurais fait qu'edf 5 août or ces
cinq classes ua qui demandait ce qu'on
peut quitter le ton est bêtement tu mets
pas parties suivantes qu'à monsieur
cassure à effet une cassure en fait
preuve monsieur et du coup tu joueras
pas les parties à la suivante
non mais t'as pas le droit
c'est une nouvelle supporters du tfc
reste ça fait dix ans que bordeaux gagne
et je les suis quand même un bandeau un
anonyme pour souvenir je t'ai le stade
avec maso victoire en finale de coupe de
la ligue contre contre lyon mon souvenir
la tong et 5 la boulette à c'est la
boulette il enfile un mode party jusque
là et je suis pas que la séraphin
academy mais j'ai quand même le plus
bavard eyes et une bonne partie et
santana partie qu'on va a su parce qu'il
reste 2 minutes 40 matches dans le
tournoi j'avais pas vu un nous avons le
classement et le classement à monsieur
finir ouais ça à faire baril est remonté
comme prévu elle avive lulu qui peut
essayer de gratter la troisième place
n'ont fait que ça gagne pas de vent et
oui elle donc du coup dans la vie si on
essaie des noirs qui étaient bien servis
des blancs ou de la partie du coup il en
strict anonymat qui l'a 39 ou 40 le
faire podium le frère 40 et peut faire
podium suivant ce qui se passe mais faut
qu'ils gagnent il reste deux minutes lot
encore une minute à la pendule faut que
les non-juifs vite et bien
il de plus le conseil jouer vite et bien
prend tout son sens mature non f2c ne
forcez de obligé
peu la gagne à mon ami avec les noirs ça
peut être chaud pour ces deux prises
prises ou bien où roger 2 prend le cadre
peut-être après on en voit et on tente
le tout pour le tout on envoie le
va-tout mais où est-ce 5-1 et de mal
j'ai trois dames j'ai deux tours b 1 ça
peut faire le taf
ouais vrai il peut faire bref un gage
pour un croche conjugales
ouais mais bon il lui reste 40 secondes
il va gagner deux secondes par coup
normalement il a 30 secondes pour gagner
ouais mais en réalité il ya le plus 2
qui te fait très mal
qui te fait très très mal il reste unie
de tournoi ça c'est bien joué de 9,4
faut un chien qui gaine
la méthode est de leur donner deux
tombes elles-mêmes et non non et non
tomber ainsi gagné là d'abord étudier
leurs oreilles tu prenais la dame après
tout rejet de h5 c'est pas mal hein bas
mais c'est fini facile et plan attendre
c'est fini mamie il va pas attendre base
si ben tu attends pas être moi je
propose nul dans ces cas là tu veux
prendre deux points non ils abandonnent
manu choco moi je propose une lancée
cadre est absolument rien à faire
atteint du coup je comprends pas il faut
mettre un jour au classement sur rfm et
agences du coup sa fille il va il est 4
pour le moment vives lui un pic à l'expo
a gagné en attendre un oui du coup
c'était que trop allostream ouais en
fait on n'est pas le classement à jour
probablement et ou alors exploit mis des
points et barbarians mais par marianne
il est quand même un comble mais
qu'est-ce que son score total il a fait
53 il a fait 15 me sur 18
il a la réussite il faut bien et 14 sur
16 pour expo donc quelque part expo un
meilleur ratio mais il finit 2e
barbarian qui a fait le taf et plus les
morts de faim ils n'affrontent est vive
vivi lulu chess qui a fait 4 way bien
joué en vivent à vue lui
donc on va écouter n'hésitez pas à
mettre un petit falloir la chaîne faut
aussi laïques et ma chaîne perso vous
avez lien juste juste en dessous je vais
mettre ma chaîne youtube aussi parce que
ça te plaisir on est passé au dessus des
40 mille a beau mais les environs de
stick ouais ouais
l'objectif 10950 ça sera dur c'est
pourquoi dans ce jeu là c'est une
question morale dans six mois on dira si
sept mois ah bin là en ce moment et
merci à issou pour pour le sol merci
il ay ay ay sous tu vois et mon gré fall
away qui a fait 13 victoires 5 défaites
et 1 défaite c'est trop il faut qu'il
m'aide la serrure faut fermer la porte
beaucoup trop j'arrive à un regret nous
on avait vu contraint de céder contre
banane verte la première partie allant
compris talent un stérilet le plat du
dernier disparu non cryptage qui a pas
dû jouer tout le tournoi mais écrite mal
qu'on retrouvera bientôt quoi je suis
mauvais sur internet objectif progresser
donnez moi un répertoire facile je fais
facile deux points de plus c'est ici
rilov
elle n'est pas facile à répertoire ça
peut faire
on a commencé avec fable en fait on veut
faire tout un truc de vidéo payante et
où tu vois pas on veut gagner du fric
avec leurs yeux clairs surface non non
on veut faire des petites vidéos là on a
prévu de faire un petit truc sur la
carreau cannes et sur la française ou
quoi mais des tutos de 20 minutes est
faible en avec les blancs et c'est tous
les combien de temps les arénas c'est
tous les jours à 13h 15 et jusqu'à quand
parce qu'à la fin des candidats ben
alors attends caisse va ça va un peu
changer de format ça va rester mais ce
sera quand même streamé mais ce ne sera
pas toujours moi ce sera aussi ça me
sera encore toi on va voir mais ça va
durer ça durera aussi après les
candidats qu'est-ce qu'ils sont contents
de cette petit aréna ça permet aux gens
de
d'avoir un petit rendez vous quotidiens
ont faim on trouve ça sympa j'espère que
vous qui fait mais ça permet de pas nous
qui faisons key west et il ya une bonne
partie en car au fond d un j'aurais peur
de le faire
et honnêtement tu es pas sûr de gagner
je te le dis tout de suite c'est loin
d'être sûr que tu gagnes pas ce que tu
as des mecs qui sont plus expérimentés
que toi sur le format arena qui vont
battre les joueurs plus faibles plus
vite c'est pas sûr que tu gagnes situe
la joue tous les jours après une semaine
tu auras l'entraînement et ça ira mais
la première que tu fais c'est pas sûr ça
va être fortement gagne évitera aux
préfets il faut faire du sale est ce qu
on pense que le temps avec moi pourra
jouer avant l'été moi je pense pas ben
ça paraît bizarre ce qu'ils ont chacun
dans leur pays et genre là les états
unis ce sont des koné pour pouvoir
sortir du pays ou du moins pour les
accepter faut être con comme la non mais
là c'est non mais le problème en fait
c'est quand ça ira aux états unis ça ira
de nouveau plus en chine quand sarah
avait plus en chine serait à nouveau
puis en russie fin ça va faire le guen
le fait qu'ils aient en fait les faits
qui est des personnes de qui viennent de
partout que ce soit europe et russie et
chine les etats unis c'est dire que pour
qu'il ait lieu faut que ça aille bien
partout et même si on aimerait que ce
soit très bientôt
ça ne prend pas la tournure à yaya
poutine qui va parler au peuple russe
aujourd'hui à la télé il va envoyer du
lourd
en fait la réussite était censé faire
ils ont fermé vendredi dernier tous
fermés et en gros les spécialistes
disaient que le pic de l'épidémie se
serait mercredi et que vendredi samedi
ce serait déjà fini
bon sinon quand même très très bien
organiser quoi mais mais du coup ils se
rendent compte qu'en fait non il se
passe le même scénario dans tous les
autres pays du monde
bon c'est quand même la reprise générale
à la surprise générale et est donc en
fait le confinement de l'est s'arrêter
demain après déjà une semaine de
confinement et bomba ce truc c'est qu'il
ya de plus en plus de malades tous les
jours et que les cas la surprise
générale
peut-être qu'ils vont devoir le
prolonger nous n'y pensons vraiment pas
moi c'est l'angleterre qui me fait peur
[Musique]
mais pour te dire la puissance
médiatique en russie j'en ai même
discuté avec vlad et même là tu as qui
porte en lui tous les trucs et tous les
non mais tu sais les russes sont
beaucoup mieux préparés à ce genre de
chose depuis l'époque soviétique machin
et le problème va être beaucoup mieux
géré mais c'est marrant à quel point son
confiance encore ma maman ils ont
peut-être moins confiant mais je dire en
fait ça a bien marché le fefa ils ont
dit pendant longtemps que ça allait bien
se passer et les gens y ont cru quoi
mais la liste est aussi une différence
de mentalité c'est que tout ce qui a été
fait en chine corée c'est finalement ce
sont bien mieux mais juste en france tu
peux c'est le gouvernement te parle
comme ça t'es pas content non plus ouais
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont faim on va
mourir par un train non non c'était pas
mais du coup c'était moi c'était par
rapport aux candidats que jc ça dans le
fait où en plus ils doivent être
rejoints en russie est là en russie en
fait c'est le même scénario qui se passe
avec deux trois semaines de retard sur
nous quand ce sera fini chez eux avec du
retard nous on aura pris la deuxième
vague fin ça me paraît interminable en
fait cette histoire mais confiné vous
bien hyper ou une amie 14,6 à nac un
homme libre guen mais je dois dire bien
jouer narrow en réalité parce que
prendre que 14 histoire gresser ouais
mais tu te rappelles quand on a essayé
tête avait commenté le speech snv elle
n'a qu'à mais c'était pas cette année il
ya deux ans ouais mais genre c'était en
5 + 2 il y avait genre 4 4 quand on
arrive en 3 + 2 ou jeu puis kalou ses
trois plus sain tout d'un coup il ya
chez pas 5-4 6-5 et tout d'un coup en
fait l'attrait 5 ou j'exagère un peu
mais tout d'un coup dakar il a peut-être
mis à 8,1 et 8,2 à maxime ans et en plus
c'était décadence qui favorisait plus
maxime konarka son commencer par le 5 +
1 est hélas ils ont sûrement dû jouer
leurs matchs en 3 + 0 ce qui est pire
contre dung quât donc moi je trouve que
14,6 contre nac atépa ridicule ouais
mais quand on fait
c'était plus dans le fait que l'autre
jour vous voyez que c'est hyper
équilibré contre nommé peau n'est pas ok
kaka plus des lots jusque d'un camion
mais sur internet est clairement 3 + 0
sur internet maka c'est un monstre
ok merci tout le monde merci mathieu et
ben on se retrouve pas son nouvel aréna
demain à 13h15 normalement avec sami
puis avec moi tu sais pas quand on se
retrouvera du coup je vois un moment
mais on sent on se retrouvera bientôt
avec toi aussi avec fava et tout le
monde le week-end et peut-être peut-être
dimanche ou lundi on va voir où mardi je
sais pas faut que je discute pour voir
exactement comme on va me dire à justin
on va faire ça donc j'ai pas tout le
monde je n'ai pas le temps je passe une
pub mathieu pour que les gens
soutiennent un petit peu de chasse comme
pour pour ses live au quotidien on vous
remercie d'avoir suivi et on vous
retrouve très bientôt ciao ciao youtube